- [Man] I thought I was
really competitive
at first and then
I played you in basketball
at VM 7 realized I'm
not competitive at all.
- [Gary] Okay.
- [Man] And then I had
to step up my game.
Do you think you
get more competitive
with the people that
are around you or--
- [Gary] Yes.
Actually, you know what?
I'm so proud of you
for asking this question.
Actually, I really do,
I'm surprised
I'm so excited by this.
I have a good
piece of advice, actually.
Start trimming your friend group
and start adding to
your friend group
predicated on what
you want to be.
The answer is
absolutely, my man.
Like, you, I am stunned how
much more I am like my wife
and how much more she is like me
even though we started
at very polar places,
it's just true.
Who you hang out with,
there is such a smart hack
to like, that cliché thing like
you are the byproduct of
the people all that,
that's real. Super real.
So maybe this is a good year
for you to kind of audit
that first day back,
look around,
maybe know a friend of a friend
and if you like what you see
go explore it and try to be
around it because, yeah man,
I think that you got more
competitive by being around me
and I can tell you right now,
I know everybody on
my team, they're different.
I'll tell you one thing that
I can tell you firm about DRock
and Nate, for sure,
I'll give you those two examples
they're a fuck load more
confident than they were
when they came
into my life because
my confidence
rubbed off on them.
Straight up.
(hip hop music)